what I teach a lot about is where are
the lines between cultural exchange and
appropriation right cultural exchange
can be great
obviously that's how the world works
whether you like it or not people
exchange ideas and within exchange ideas
they exchange aesthetics people like to
surround themselves with beautiful
things people like to put beautiful
things on their bodies at least a lot of
people do and so these things are going
to be exchanged but how do you do that
in a way that benefits everyone involved
and gives the people who are the kind of
core of this aesthetic a core of this
style the credit that they deserve and a
lot of it does have to do with giving
credit where it's due
whether that be monetarily whether that
just be in reference in saying this is
where I got this idea or whether that
being really letting them take the lead
within that kind of design or that
aesthetic and you kind of acting more
supportively
if you really want to work in that same
aesthetic right but you kind of have to
go from a perspective of your being
invited into this I think the problem is
that there is still this mentality and a
lot of again I'm gonna say the Western
world but in a lot of spaces that we can
go and take and this is something pretty
and I'm gonna go buy this and I'm gonna
use this and I'm going to make it
something that's my own and that's fine
without having to acknowledge where
those ideas where those aesthetics came
from and so I do think that idea of kind
of picking right it's like that old like
the British archaeologist goes into
Egypt and just take stuff brings it back
to the British Museum and and nobody
says anything about it until however
many hundreds of years later and then
all of a sudden people like I should
probably go back to Egypt so I think
that's that's the issue too is there is
this history of kind of like going into
spaces taking and then leaving which is
something that anthropology has been
trying to get around for ages someone's
opinion may contradict yours where's my
friend Alan it's all about your
who are we in what is the nature of this
reality what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are still on site at the American
Anthropological Association Annual
Meeting in Vancouver British Columbia
for our second partnership with them we
are now going to be talking about
fashion anthropology and so much more we
have on the east bar either joining us
on the show high knees high on the
program thank you for inviting me I'm
excited to be here likewise very pumped
to be interviewing you honey she's a PhD
candidate in cultural anthropology at
the University of South Carolina and I'm
pumped to dive into the depth you've
been that Ecuador five times you're now
doing a PhD thesis on this topic that
we're gonna get to but we want to take
things from a perspective of we love
asking our guests about all this
big-picture stuff that's happening are
we really all one well that's a very big
question as you will know there's lots
of ways to look at that if you're
looking at kind of various scales and as
anthropologists we kind of like to piece
apart okay what context are we talking
about who and/or what are we talking
about but if you want to pull back and
go to kind of the biggest scale say
universally are we all one I think to
some extent the answer would be yes and
whether we like it or not and I say that
because I think a lot of people aren't
consciously thinking of their connection
to whether the other human beings or
even kind of the natural environment or
even the built environment or even what
I work with is material culture so the
objects we use in daily life how those
actually mediate relationships right
that we are all interconnected in
particular ways because that means
that you have more of a responsibility
than you might be willing to take on you
know we like to think about if we're all
interconnected then we have this great
possibility to affect change and we
always think that is a very positive
thing but it also means you have the
ability to affect negative change right
even that you're not necessarily
conscious of so I do think there is this
kind of ebb and flow where things kind
of work together and and in that sense I
think yes we're all kind of part of this
information universe feeding back on
itself so no matter what way we really
look at the origin of how we're here it
all goes back to one whether you call it
a source or God or an all that is or
universe or Big Bang whatever you want
to call it the one all of these
pluralistic coexisting ideologies
philosophies religions point back to a
way that we find ourselves here and the
reason being what do you think why are
we here I don't think I have an answer
for that I don't think many people do
that's why there are several answers to
that that's why philosophy deals with
that that's why the arts deal with that
anthropology specifically deals with
that through the actions of people so
we're looking at why do people behave
the way they do in groups with one
another why do they react to their
environment in particular ways and all
of that is going to be very very
context-specific right so you kind of
have to pull back this idea of okay
what's our purpose and really look at
instead okay what's my purpose in this
moment effecting change with these
people around me what's my purpose
within the society as opposed to what's
my purpose outside of the society
because for many people there isn't
necessarily this purpose outside of the
society you know in some communities it
very much is what happens to the commune
happens to you and vice versa so you
know I would say broadly yeah I don't
have an answer for that I can look at it
from different contexts for different
individuals I can say broadly speaking
my purpose is to create more empathy and
I think that for most anthropologists
they would say the end goal is to create
more empathy so that we can coexist in
ways that are beneficial not just to
ourselves but to again the natural
environment the built environment beyond
ourselves
so that's kind of maybe at the core of
the core of anthropology as a discipline
but I'm sure there would be arguments
from other disciplines there's a
different purpose I really like the
purpose of bringing more empathy to the
world trying to get behind the eyes of
all different types of walks of life I
really like that a lot trying to design
architect a social fabric that enables
everyone to flourish and bring their
unique gifts forth that treats the
biosphere as though it isn't all
interconnected does it feel like the
most upstream issue are our feelings of
lack of interconnectedness our feelings
of separation and that's causing all the
downstream symptomatic I mean I think
that again you're saying we I think that
to a certain extent that feeling of
disconnectedness is very much a a
Western feeling and particularly like a
Western us feeling of and you know
they've done Studies on and how let's
say white must Western men feel very
disconnected right they don't have a
place and they're losing an idea of like
who they are in this world and I would
say that a lot of that has to do with
capitalism and consumerism and the way
that it plays out in the Western world
because again we don't want to take
these overarching ideas like capitalism
without situating them in a particular
context cultural context of social
context so I would say that yes that's a
huge problem and I would say that it's
an expand
problem as kind of globalization as a
process has always existed but
globalization has exist today some of
the Western ideology is including
individuals and consumerism and things
like this
they might contribute to kind of this
feeling of loss of community this
feeling of not being able to empathize
with other people because you feel
isolated yourself is then what we can
take from areas of indigeneity again
needing to put it into specific context
just indigeneity that has deep roots in
interconnectedness with all and doing
things like being able to marry that
with modernity and metropolis is respect
for the air you breathe the water you
drink the food you eat the other humans
you would never tell people lies you
would never try and self deal for
yourself you share the extra gathering
that you get with everyone they do the
same thing when they bring it back are
these some of the principles that need
to be brought into the modernity in
order for us to flourish the best we can
yes I would say that certain principles
which we associate with indigeneity with
particular groups because again we don't
want to look at indigenous just one kind
of monolithic thing but there are
certain kind of principles that that
come up within indigenous groups that
should be integrated into modernity but
again it's also problematic to kind of
put this dichotomy between indigeneity
and modernity because that's part of
what I looked at is how we historicize
indigenous populations and how we
relegate them to the Past to this older
way of thought to these older practices
when they've been practicing these
things alongside us in modern
contemporary culture you know to be an
indigenous person in the world is to be
a contemporary so yes I think it's not
just integrating into modern life I
think it's integrating it into certain
again kind of Western particularly u.s.
ideologies that are coming from these
hegemonic institutions
albeit there is a lot of complexity that
goes post using the word indigeneity
understandably so many different
combinatoric of indigenous life in order
for one to aim to disseminate awakening
messaging to a myriad of worldviews
around the planet it is really helpful
to try and synthesize and try and boil
things down and it does seem like if you
put a big plus sign in between
indigeneity and modernity and put that
up as a meme people would at least
somewhat understand from just two words
in a plus sign kind of what you're
getting at yeah in terms of trying to
drive society forward in a direction
that is more beneficial yeah and Canada
is doing it in many ways quite well they
respect their First Nations of a like
quite a bit from what I've heard and
seen while being here and the US has a
history of having like an order of
magnitude more people and a a economy
that's significantly larger and just
more complexity with the indigenous that
were first here when we came plus the
entire southern part of the United
States that had a lot of other Central
Americans that were there as well as an
Americans in general that were there the
transatlantic slave trade also Japanese
internment camps I mean there's just
like there's a never-ending list of
problematic issues that the u.s. faced
and so there's really tough to figure
out the traumatic healing that needs to
happen but it does start with the actual
process of truly aiming to heal said
things and its really its opportunity
the biggest powers I think
the top of the wealthiest people the
biggest corporations the biggest
government's to truly propagate means of
unconditional love and inclusive stake
holding and and the emerging markets all
the emerging technologies try and
democratize the fruits instead of have
the 1% take 50% of the emerging fruits
of those markets I mean the principles I
think are quite more common sensical
than we're then we even we just
anthropologists are very good at
explaining the sheer complexity of
things but if we can boil it down to
like mm-hmm
like a 5th grader in graphs on like what
needs to happen I think overall the
planets like yeah that's like pretty
much the reality of it yeah well and
well one of the things I believe is that
anthropology should be taught very very
early on that people some students do
get it in high school now but generally
speaking those are going to be from kind
of wealthier areas and there's not a lot
of widespread anthropology in high
school let alone things like middle
school in elementary school and it's not
that it's such a complex discipline that
you can't teach it I mean really what
we're talking about is again how humans
behave and how humans behave in groups
and that's the very core of how we exist
in daily life it's very strange to me
that we don't start teaching about it
and teaching about variations in
diversity and empathy and all these
things at a very very young age and so
first I would say I think I think that
would be hugely beneficial and then just
in terms of kind of where does this work
needs to come from and simplification I
think that simply simplification is
useful in terms of if you want to market
something right you want the the
cleanest idea you want something people
can have an emotional attachment to and
they process it and that's going to
stick in their head and
and it's going to make them buy this
thing or go to this place or whatever it
might be and it but I also think that we
need to give people a little bit more
credit because I think a lot of people
do get that first kind of taste of this
is what this is about or this is the
main idea and when they feel comfortable
with that they do start to get
interested in ok let's go deeper let's
look at the context let's look at the
difference because it doesn't take away
from the main idea it only adds to it
it's just extra data extra support right
double-clicking in when you do get the
initial theme of interest captured then
you want to dive deeper I also like how
you put that if you get young kids
realizing that they themselves our
artists and anthropologists at the
youngest possible ages and you get them
doing things like fun fieldwork and then
create like project-based learning
around that fieldwork solving the SDGs
all this type of stuff you can have a
pretty solid foundation in childhood
education I really like the idea of
anthropology coming in at really young
ages I want to pass time getting into
like who you were growing up that gotchu
to become interested in quito and
Ecuador and indigeneity and fashion
anthropology how did you even get
interested in all this so it's been a
long journey I was born in Bolivia to a
Bolivian father an American mother when
when they met they traveled quite a bit
they lived in South America for a while
my two oldest brothers were raised there
my sister and I were born there but we
weren't raised there we were raised in
the US so I always kind of had this
strange identity because where I was
growing up was a very latina kind of
neighborhood but it was predominantly
Mexican American some Puerto
rican-american you know there were no
Bolivian Americans and pretty much my
entire youth I never saw anyone who was
like me in the sense of a Bolivian
American woman now I've kind of with
social media actually
Instagram I found you know some Bolivian
American activists artists actually a
fashion designer in California so these
people are coming up but I didn't have
social media like I do now
so I struggled a lot with my identity
because I was latina in a community with
lots of Latinas but they weren't the
same latina and so the ways that I would
dress for instance I was very aware to
not dress in ways that were specifically
let's say Mexican American which is also
your child you're naive you know
whatever else it wouldn't have mattered
but you know in my head I was looking
for kind of my own identity both within
and outside of that at the same time
which is very difficult so my mother was
always interested in an apology she's
not an anthropologist it's just
something she loved I got that love from
her but you know again being a teenager
when I decided to go to college I was
like no I'm gonna be an English major
that lasted not that long and I thought
there's great work that you can do in
English but I wanted something that was
more practical don't say practical but
it just more deeply embedded in lived
experience I guess I really I don't know
a great way to say that but I kind of
gave into anthropology because it's
something I'd always loved but I just
just trying to stay away from it got
into it ended up studying abroad in
Ecuador made friends there and then I
actually worked as a legal advocate for
domestic violence victims for a few
years and then applied to graduate
school and went back to anthropology and
so as soon as I went back I knew Ecuador
was the region I wanted to be in it was
an Indian nation so it shares a lot of
similarities with Bolivia and I wanted
to explore a place that would be both
kind of personally mattering to me
because of that context because it was
Andean because I could get a little bit
of an understanding of what my parents
were dealing with raising us or what my
dad's background was and I do feel like
I've got an insight into for instance my
father
personality much more by doing this work
so in that sense that's kind of why I
wanted to work in the Andes why I wanted
to work with processes of like mestizaje
and as far as the fashion stuff that's
just something I've always been
interested in in terms of how fashion
makes meaning and I actually didn't
realize initially that anthropology of
fashion could be a thing I didn't
realize it existed and so it wasn't
until after I got my master's that I
started kind of naturally finding other
people who had talked about the same
things oftentimes not calling them
fashion anthropologist but calling
themselves material culture people
calling themselves cultural
anthropologist with a focus on regional
dress styles things like that and so I
realized I could do it and I just went
all-in when was the first trip this was
studying abroad for undergrad for
undergrad yes what year was that
no but I honestly don't remember that
would have been over 10 years it was a
while ago
so okay so ten years ago on the first
trip you you start did you say you were
starting to do work with domestic
violence and so that was after I
graduate after you graduated doing worth
domestic violence people from so
actually I did have Ecuadorian clients
but it was here it was in the Chicago
area and I worked primarily with
immigrant women
I'm spanish-speaking interesting okay
and were they they were having domestic
issues but in the Chicago area because
we did another episode on the show here
at triple-a where it was like a forced
migration or Asylum see yeah yeah from
domestic violence in those areas okay
and it is still a huge issue with in
Ecuador yeah and with especially female
seeking refuge from domestic violence
issues yeah okay all right and then so
then then
you went back again in masters yep four
masters okay then this was when I read
this I thought okay let's talk we got to
talk about social media and smart phone
tech Quito Ecuador okay and I see how
you're you know you're trying to
understand Bolivia through Ecuador
through the unbe n' yeah area and then
also through also understanding your
father as well like you were describing
to us earlier so what are the
discoveries that you made in that
master's thesis just in general
yeah because yeah cuz i mean you also
gave us we talk a lot on the show about
the nuance of social media and yeah
there's some stuff with the attention
economy business plan models and mental
health issues and all this different
type of stuff
but there's also incredible things like
you being able to find other Bolivians
that are working in the states are on
different projects in bolivia as well
and it's just a good way to network
based on on that as well so i just want
to know so how were they using social
media and smart phone tax so the the
most interesting thing kind of the crux
of what I found out is there I was late
at the time I was there cuz it's gonna
be several years ago now but at the time
I was there there were a lot of programs
coming up to make Ecuador kind of more
of a tech-savvy media heavy environment
they had a program called yet I believe
it was I think that's the name of it oh
no yes Unni sorry I'm yes Unni and it
was supposed to be an Amazonian region
and it was supposed to be essentially
their answer to Silicon Valley and part
of what was interesting about it and so
promising and why everybody in Ecuador
was excited about it was that by doing
this by putting essentially this
university that was also kind of like a
tech hub where people could work could
study they were protecting the natural
resources underneath it because by
putting that there the president
basically said this is how we're going
to kind of make money in this region
this is how we're gonna advance this
region instead of drilling right instead
of using these natural resources
those natural resources were protected
and it was theoretically going to
benefit the community now that since has
gone nowhere it's gone but it was at
this time when these things were really
kind of pressing in Ecuador was really
trying to like figure out ways to
participate in this world and what I was
looking at specifically was how are the
divisions between the general mestizo
population so the population that we in
the US were probably called Latino
latina X that mixed mixed kind of white
Spanish ancestry with indigenous
ancestry
that's the mainstream population how is
that population using technology in ways
that differ from the indigenous
population and the government had this
rhetoric through its programs that
indigenous people needed help using
technology they needed classes they
weren't kind of as advanced or tapped in
as the general mestizo population who
was living in cities and was very mobile
and you know whatever else and I really
didn't find that to be the case
particularly with smartphones because of
the mobility of smartphones because it
didn't need the infrastructure that's
something like landlines would that
actually indigenous people were using it
and they were using it to keep up with
you know friends and relatives in
different countries who were travelling
selling goods or whatever they might be
doing so this whole narrative of the
nation-state was actually basically the
opposite this the most advanced
technology or the more advanced
technology is what they had because
that's what they were able to use let's
say you know in Highland mountains or in
more rural areas because there wasn't
the infrastructure for something like
landline telephones or like televisions
or whatever else so they would have the
most cutting-edge technology for the
this in because they were in such remote
locations to be able to communicate with
others so they would actually have like
an actual cellphone yeah they would have
like an actual smartphone and you know
it might not be the most expensive
version of that yeah you know but some
Ecuadorian mestizos in the city didn't
the most expensive version of that just
because they're very there are very high
taxes on imports in Ecuador so
technology is incredibly expensive in
general but they would have essentially
something on par with you know rest of
the metropolis even just they would have
similar tech okay okay and this is all
this is also this brings up another
point from one of our interviews with
Lesley Clark on indigenous nomadic
people of Nigeria and how they are also
using telecommunications technologies
like smart phones through like whatsapp
voice messages to each other and I think
that's also really interesting for them
to pick up a technology that enables
them to do stuff like send each of those
voice messages and they've been able to
unlock a whole new array of of behaviors
and of cooperative tasks that they're
able to achieve based on that so it's
it's really interesting hearing about
what what can people that are now being
introduced to like this voice technology
what can they accomplish now okay so
that's some of the the tech discoveries
that you did in the masters okay okay
and then you went then you came you came
back yep and then you decided to do
University of South Carolina for the PhD
in anthropology and then it want you
wanted to go again to study Ecuador yes
at this time through a more of a fashion
through biological wines mm-hmm okay
take us on this okay so when I was doing
my masters fieldwork I had already
started unknowingly thinking about my
PhD fieldwork
because I was already asking questions
about dress one of the people that I
interviewed who's known as like one of
his name's like the key to a gamer he
does robotics but he's kechi which is an
indigenous population from the area so
he always when he's when there are
newspaper articles written about him or
TV shows highlighting him whatever it
may be he's I would say always I don't
I'm trying to think of a time when I
haven't seen him wearing it but he wear
like traditional garb at the very least
he'll wear the poncho with kind of the
white traditional white pant and shirt
underneath as a means of representing
his indigeneity in these very high-tech
spaces right to help kind of break this
dichotomy again what we're talking about
between indigeneity and modernity this
idea that there not one in the same and
so he's very openly using this dress as
kind of a marker a cue of identity
indigeneity oh that's in modernity of
his exactly of indigeneity within
modernity exactly yeah I've actually
noticed that we had a Kogi elder on the
show from Colombia and they also wear it
all white they have a very distinct hat
they have their very distinct items that
they carry with them very spiritual
items and you can tell you know they're
striped eggs that they have and it's
just like that's interesting so clothing
exterior clothing can also be a tell of
where someone is in there what
subculture they belong to and digitally
mm-hmm in the middle of like a busy
street in a metropolis absolutely and
it's one of those things what I like to
look at is how this creates what I call
semiotic communities but talking about
it not through language but through the
language of dress yeah so essentially
there's lots of different subgroups
there's 14 recognised indigenous nations
within Ecuador but that's because one of
those nations is just Quechua
which actually is a language not
necessarily just a population and within
that there's actually several different
populations so the budva who I work with
are considered Keetoowah sometimes when
it's like talked about in like tourist
brochures or whatever else they may be
kind of wrapped into that but they
consider themselves their own specific
cultural group pronounced this again the
blue ha budhwa rua yeah it's the accent
is at the end
the key to a language structure but okay
they so they have particular regional
dress and other groups that are
considered key to are within the kind of
key to a broader designation all have
regional styles so if you have enough
knowledge about it you see somebody
walking down the street you can tell
okay that person's from otavalo that
person from Rio Bamba you know you can
see what even towns and provinces people
are from if you have that knowledge but
in order to have that knowledge for the
most part either you're part of the
community or you study it right so if
you are part of that community and you
and this actually did happen to one of
my interviewees she was talking about
the fact that she went to the US and she
was I think in st. Louis or someplace
and she was going to a church and she
saw a woman wearing a specific regional
dress style that she recognized and she
was just like overwhelmed yeah because
you know that's my person I I know
exactly where that person is from not
just I know what country that person is
from based on their accent or whatever
else but I know what province and town
you're from and community whole of name
or two out of mine yeah it's a very much
so very much so within my community a
lot of people know each other the some
of the fashion designers I work with
that are the most prominent
I learned this too late in the field the
first time around but I should have been
name-dropping
because as soon as I did people were
like oh yeah I know that brand I know
that designer like I really love her
stuff you know etc etc so there
definitely is this community get that
gets built just based on being able to
recognize that person yeah so then does
this then become something that we can
have the influence of consumeristic
capitalistic modernity just you know in
in a non like ethically thought-out way
just take take root in I mean it just
those things don't feel like we get that
they that there's this beautiful way of
like having decorating this sacred
vehicle of the body and then being able
to see somebody else and like that's so
profoundly interesting like to be able
to do that but then when it becomes like
there's just something about it that
when it like when someone goes and like
I don't know could you imagine like an
indigenous division to like Louis
Vuitton or something like where they go
and like try and like make you know like
work with indigenous people there to try
and make like really high-priced or even
like you know low price from like I
don't know Nike or something let me find
out how to do it or whatever but just
like or even just an it or even just an
independent fashion designer that then
like makes a you know like an Instagram
account for the Peru huh and then
decides to to work with them and give
them money and then they get fueled by
you know capitalism to get out of
poverty is like what the cell is mmm-hmm
how do you feel about all of that it's
complex one the designers I think one of
the issues choose I'm looking at it at a
very local context slash national
context I'm looking at it in the context
of Ecuador right now and so mestizo
people in Ecuador aren't wearing
indigenous clothing they have access to
it and they can afford some of them can
afford I mean I'm talking about also
like there's you know obviously class
issues that go into this different you
know other factors that go into this but
some designers are very very high-end
they're making very expensive pieces so
sisa who is one of the designers I work
with her Brenda sumac should I
and one of her blouses could cost around
140 dollars right so that's especially
in Ecuador where the income level I want
to say its average like 300 a month
something like that it's a very very
expensive piece and it is all Couture
Sheehan makes it I've seen her make them
so these are very expensive pieces but
you know there are wealthier people in
Ecuador whether they be indigenous or
mestizo or something else part of the
immigrant population who can afford
these pieces but they're not necessarily
going to wear them and I argue that
there are several reasons for that part
of it having to do with the history of
racism which I'm sure you know part of
it having to do with the process of
mestizaje there which is this process of
whitening that when the Spanish came
people started mixing they freaked out
and obviously they're always gonna like
preference whiteness right so trying to
whiten people so basically have more
white partners so that slowly you know
the population becomes wider and wider
but because of this process of mixing
unlike to an extent again all of us has
variations but to an extent unlike in
the US where they came in and just wiped
out the population there was a much more
subtle kind of wiping out but in that
process it means that a lot of mestizo
people look like indigenous people I
could pass for indigenous there if I
wore that style of dress I have like
sisa has about the same in tone as me we
have similar features things like that
and so I I do one of the arguments I
make is that these kind of lingering
ideas this fear of passing as one or the
other
keeps them from wearing indigenous dress
but I think it also is a respect thing
understanding that this is part of also
culture and heritage and not wanting to
take that not wanting to appropriate
that yeah so it's kind of both sides of
the coin that's a market opportunity
really right it's a market opportunity
to cut down trees and you know build
houses with them
right there's got to be a point where we
figure out its market opportunity for me
to burn fossil fuels pollute the air
right there's got to be a point right
yeah yeah and at some point people are
they are somewhat self-aware like maybe
this is it for me that's not to say that
there aren't mestizo people white people
in Ecuador who are appropriating
indigenous let's say patterns and
designs because certainly that happens a
lot of these like folk art galleries
when you go down there they're really
beautifully curated galleries some of
them have indigenous things but some of
them are you know mestizo made things or
even what I'm saying white so likes just
Spanish or just let's say German
immigrants or something like that these
people making things sometimes in
conjunction with indigenous communities
but sometimes not and even when they are
in conjunction with indigenous
communities they're not saying I worked
with this indigenous designer they're
saying I worked with this community and
I did so much good and I helped them and
but this my name is on this because this
is my design so there's issues like that
that I harness and call this like
extractive versus like community driven
class yeah and so that would be what I
would worry about if let's say there was
a movement in the u.s. there was an
interest in this style and these very
high-end well-known designers start
working with indigenous communities
because we see it in the u.s. that there
are Fairtrade brands that there are
these companies that you know will sell
shoes with weavings on them that are
indigenous but they don't talk about the
indigenous designers as designers as
artists they talk about them as a
community in need that they're helping
and it still marked as their brand not
as a brand coming from within the
community so I would worry about that
but I will say within the u.s. that US
native designers have been doing an
excellent job just there are some
beautiful us designers be yellowtail is
one of the
she has an amazing line of clothing that
I cannot afford but I wish I could so a
lot of this is just I don't even think
you need that collaboration is basically
what I'm trying to get at I think
they're you know these designers are
doing it for themselves they're much
more entrepreneurial than I am they they
have amazing I mean they're just amazing
talented designers regardless of
background and so I don't think that
they need that help I think they're
gonna get there one way or the other and
in part I think they're going to get
there because I think people are
becoming disillusioned with those other
high-end brands are we are weak are we
talking like macro level perspective
there's different subcultures of
indigeneity across the world that all
have their own unique like patterns and
clothing styles and ways to make shoes
and ways to make pots and pottery and
all different kinds of things and then
we're talking about like someone either
like goes to one of those subcultures
and like learns that process and brings
it back and then to their home land
that's but that is a modern place and
then they themselves decide to create a
business around what they learned and
then then the some of them more I guess
so this is where someone could say like
a problematic issue occurs when maybe
the person does not acknowledge
whatsoever where they learned there's
craft from this art from if they don't
care at all about giving back in some
way again like what do you do when you
give back what does that even mean how
do you do that how do you give
recognition how do you tell a story
about though about that so it preserves
the subculture that we're talking about
so that's the macro-level yeah I mean
this concept of what I teach a lot about
is where are the lines between cultural
exchange and appropriation right
cultural exchange can be great obviously
that's how the world works whether you
like it or not people exchange ideas and
with in exchange ideas they exchanged
aesthetics people like to surround
themselves with beautiful things people
like to put beautiful things on their
bodies at least a lot of people do and
so these things are going to be
exchanged but how do you do that in a
way that benefits everyone involved and
gives the people who are the kind of
core of this aesthetic or core of this
style the credit that they deserve and a
lot of it does have to do with giving
credit where it's due
whether that be monetarily whether that
just be in reference in saying this is
where I got this idea or whether that
being really letting them take the lead
within that kind of design or that
aesthetic and you kind of acting more
supportively if you really want to work
in that same aesthetic right but you
kind of have to go from a perspective of
your being invited into this I think the
problem is that there is still this
mentality and a lot of again I'm gonna
say the Western world but in a lot of
spaces that we can go and take and this
is something pretty and I'm gonna go buy
this and I'm gonna use this and I'm
going to make it something that's my own
and that's fine without having to
acknowledge where those ideas where
those aesthetics came from and so I do
think that idea of kind of taking right
it's like that old like the British
archaeologist goes into Egypt and just
take stuff brings it back to the British
Museum and and nobody says anything
about it until however many hundreds of
years later and then all of a sudden
people are like I should probably go
back to Egypt so I think that's that's
the issue too is there is this history
of kind of like going into spaces taking
and then leaving which is something that
anthropology has been trying to get
around for ages that one yeah that's
interesting cultural exchange versus
appropriation and what the hell's in the
nuance of that so culture yeah exactly
and cultural exchange is gonna again be
that more balanced what does that mean
we're balanced and what does it means
again a asking you know asking them when
you're there
hey would it be okay so that's the first
step yep
okay so yeah let's do this breakdown
yeah point number one so let's let's
just come up with a scenario because
that's the easiest way to like have this
imaginary because there's all nuances to
all different types right there's a
difference if you're staying with the
host family and they want you to wear
traditional dress to a family gathering
versus if you're just going in and
you're like let me throw on a kimono so
let's say you're going to latin-american
indigenous community you really like
something the weaving pattern right so
the first thing you might want to do if
you like this weaving pattern or you
like this aesthetic and you're like oh I
kind of want to I want to use some of
that ask like your clothing is what it
comes to mind like what if they had
picked that pattern right you know boats
sail boats that are like that and is
this is this a very widespread pattern
already does it exist in multiple spaces
is there anything sacred exactly is
there anything sacred or very kind of
deeply personal for the heritage or the
community or the family that it would be
strange like you don't want to put a
sacred print on a pair of thong right or
wrong underwear that kind of idea of
like okay where is this going also so
what does this mean to the community
directly asking would you be okay if I
use this or something similar
also similarity if it's there's a
difference between wearing a full kimono
right or having a dress that you design
that has a kimono sleeve it just has a
you know that shape of sleeve that's
different so there's there's levels of
nuance right and and maybe a couple
sailboats instead of just a whole sheet
Oh exactly right or maybe it's okay to
have it on a blouse but not necessarily
like you don't want it on shoes because
there's something associated with feet
in the dirt or something exactly so
there's all these little nuances but and
in order to have good more or less it's
there's always going to be a power
imbalance woman
the other for whatever reason but as
equal as you can get it part of that the
basis of that is having knowledge and
seeking that knowledge out honestly and
one of the problems is with these
corporations or even with these high-end
designers is they don't care because
they know they can make the money off it
and then you know when it's called
appropriation by the community or the
other designer if let's say it's an
indigenous designer calls them out for
what they're doing they'll just kind of
either pay it off we're gonna let it
fade in the background because that
designer doesn't have the clout yet
doesn't have the status yet to really
make enough waves that it would put this
let's say louboutin out of business
right so yeah so that's kind of that
really the core of whether it's cultural
exchange or appropriation has lots to do
with knowledge and has a lot to do with
just straight up asking and power trying
to keep power as balanced as possible
damn Wow okay so this is really
interestingly complex you know who would
have thought that yeah that's something
like a fashion anthropology would come
down to cultural exchange versus
appropriation in in many ways and I
think this is that's that's a really
interesting point within the fashion
anthropology and actually you were
mentioning this earlier too is just in
archaeology's had the same problem of
cultural exchange versus appropriation
because you this is happening where all
the artifacts from before they make it
to all these museums in these metropolis
where do they come from indigenous
people are mad because they lots a lot
of them were put there by indigenous
people for very specific sacred reasons
that we then bury we dig them up and
then put them in the museums and then
there are imbalances that occur in
natural areas because we don't
understand that type of intelligence and
we're trying to use rationality for
something that may be a little bit more
intuitive that rational and he needs to
somehow be able to understand but it's
trying I don't know
it's hard because intuition can
sometimes also be strangely wrong I
guess also yeah because yeah anyway so
do you have this big issue with cultural
appropriation versus exchange happening
and you figure out like is this just a
sleeve of the kimono is this the whole
thing is this just a little tiny three
boats of the pattern is this on the
whole entire or it putting us on
wallpaper now is this not supposed to go
on the shoes or a thong is it supposed
to go only on like a sacred maybe
earring or something and how do you ask
how do you even ask when I go there and
I see something great you know what do I
say how do i how do I engage them in if
I am a massive corporation that's
completely different than if I'm just
like some independent you know kid
that's coming to visit that it just
became fascinated and wants to be a
cultural exchange anthropologist with
that may be so I mean what would you
like what would that circumstance it
look like if I'm you know if I'm just
kid and I only have that much power and
I'm really interesting cultural exchange
versus if you're a corporation and you
have that much power and you're trying
to ask them questions about where you
can actually put that pattern well I
think let's say if you're just a kid
going in I think a lot of times the
stuff you're gonna encounter anyway some
of that is going to be for sale right
some of that is going to be things that
you kind of know at the outset at least
I can purchase those things because
those things are being sold directly to
me regardless of whether or not I can
take that and then use it for my own
product but really it's about regardless
of if you're a big company or an
individual person it's about building
community and that's kind of the answer
sometimes people don't want to hear
because that's the answer that takes
time you really have to spend time with
people and you know it's one of those
things in Latin America it's still kind
of a thing in a lot of open-air markets
whether it be a food market or you know
an artisan market or whatever that you
have one vendor and you
go back to that vendor and you build
trust with that vendor and they start
giving you deals or they start finding
things specifically for you so it's a
different way of kind of doing business
or shopping it's based as much on that
relationship that you make with your
certain let's say tomato seller as it
would be like here like oh I just want
to find the prettiest tomatoes or the
best tomatoes a lot of its based on that
relationship and so if you're going
about it that way you build a
relationship with the person you talk to
the person you get to know things about
their culture you ask them and as long
as I would say obviously human beings
are all different but I would say as
long as someone's being genuine with you
and kind of asking things in a way
that's respectful then you'll get your
answers but with companies I think the
problem is again they don't want to do
that work they don't want to send
somebody down there for months at a time
so they can build these relationships so
that they can find out you know if it's
okay to use this pattern some of them
maybe do try I'm not sure you know and
it's gonna be different again between
like a high-end couture designer versus
let's say somebody who's doing like free
trade an online website or something but
but really that's the crux of it it
takes time it takes relationships yeah
that was that was an interesting point
that you bring up from this that whether
it be so many of the different
anthropologists that we've talked to or
other people that we've had on the show
that are going back and hanging out with
people from different subcultures around
the world it's fascinating because the
ones that continuously go back and build
community are the ones that gain the
deepest connections with other people's
psyche and their lineage and then it
doesn't feel like it feels more like
cultural exchange instead of
appropriation you know like you said
it's the time it's the relationships the
community with that it just feels weird
even in the first place for some reason
having indigenous subcultures from
around the world like
selling things there's such a strange
thing here cuz it's like selling it
both awakens people to that indigenous
cultural item and artifact and what it
means if it's sacred you know all that
cool stuff yeah but then it also loops
the whole process into like the
transactional economic machinery which
then takes them out of poverty which is
always the message that is propagated by
capitalism and then the and then some of
the things happen like we're talking to
Ramona Perez on the show about how over
time it was actually that as the
indigenous community indigenous
subculture near Oaxaca City actually had
more of resources that they were using
for making the the pottery they actually
had to start using more lead instead of
less led in that pottery and then over
time they got lead poisoning from that
process and so there's economic
machinery causes like it cannot have a
cause like health issues like that too
so there's there's so much complexity
here basically is it that your work you
want to just shine a big like flashlight
on this field and this and this a
fashion anthropology and cultural
exchange misappropriation at large yes
particularly because I think it is
something that keeps happening
I keep seeing news articles about things
like appropriating indigenous stress or
indigenous aesthetics in one way or the
other we still have museums not all
museums a lot of museums have been doing
a great job with things like
repatriation but there are still museums
who don't do such a great job and who
don't do such a great job in knowing how
to display certain things versus other
things so we still we still very much
have this culture of take and so just to
kind of talk about what are the
alternatives to that and also yes just
to shine a light because I don't think
even with inequity where I remember
talking to a friend of mine a couple
friends of mine
and there you know mestizos they had no
idea that within their own country that
Pedulla designers were doing all this
work and so I was explaining to them
what they were doing and you know how
much these pieces were going for and
what they looked like
and that there was a buyers market
because there is and I will say there
are mestizo and I'm saying my sisa women
because most of it is women's dress for
the designers that I work with there are
mestizos who are models for these
designers and who will buy these
products too it's just it's not as much
as the indigenous community and
oftentimes it seems it seems that those
mestizo women have either regional ties
so they might be from the same city
right in the same area or they might
have some sort of other like family or
community tie to the area it's not the
most kind of mainstream broad swath of
the population so yeah there's still
people within their own country that
have no idea that that these designs are
being done that these people and I mean
they're successful they're they're
making an income they're able to sustain
themselves on this business so this is
the next point I wanted to ask because
Ramona Perez had a very similar story
next to a Hakka City boom that
indigenous area yeah I gained the
females gained autonomy right yeah they
gained independence from the pottery but
then the increase in lead or right cause
those health issues etc well then there
was like oh my gosh what do we do now
increasing autonomy now happens yeah so
see you also see when is it is this true
that when the big move in like of an
indigenous subculture decides to enter
there but there are into the economic
machinery that then women that if they
make that art themselves they can become
autonomous they can become independent
and that can maybe decrease violence
they can maybe increase them finding out
what they actually care about and want
to do in the world and not maybe
necessarily just be you know Mary didn't
have kids and etc yeah I mean I think
just with even broader female
populations I think that
I have noticed within the proa the women
that I've worked with there are more
women who are single later who are
childless or who at least see these
things as a positive as opposed to a
negative for instance a lot of them will
obviously you know they'll ask me about
my life and their reaction to me being a
single woman in the field with a career
at 32 yeah you know hold him is a very
positive reaction right and a lot of
them also like sisa for example like she
is very independent she's done this
business herself but part of it is also
that she's brought in her female friends
to help her so some of her friends will
run the shop when she is you know sewing
in the studio or you know she's sewing
the studio so one of her friends will go
deliver a product that sold to a girl
across town she wants to hand-deliver it
because they're very finely made pieces
so she's not only helping herself she's
also helping the women around her in her
community provide them with work
providing them with work providing them
sometimes with you know spaces to stay
you know and it's much more the way she
works and I would say probably a way of
that a lot of people work from what I've
observed
it's very reciprocal it's very people
well go get food for one another if the
other person can't leave you know if
they need change they'll give each other
change and they may be competitors they
may have stores right next to each other
but they hang out they talk to each
other you know they do all these things
because again there is also that culture
of like well this is the person I go to
so I'm always gonna go to that person so
there's several reasons for that but
yeah I mean though you know make food
together hang out so it's it's
nourishing not just in the sense of
she's giving these women more economic
freedom or really they're giving it to
themselves but she's helping them get it
but also that she's there's a community
nourishment you know there's this kind
of familial relationship between women
who are working together that they might
not otherwise have so it is a sense of
Independence via literally just having
more money but also via like when your
friend succeeds you succeed yeah sounds
the social networks and the rising tide
lifts all boats hmm this is so this is
so tough to figure out because I I just
I don't know if there's like it's like
what what aspects to the excellence of
the cultural exchange part mm-hmm can be
amplified the most excellent parts of
the culture exchange part being
amplified and then there's like the
parts that are like are not balanced
there's power imbalances like you're
describing and how can you take the
appropriation 'el parts appropriative
parts how you can take those and just
decrease those or just eliminate them
completely so it becomes basically
solely focused on cultural exchange and
not on appropriation yeah honestly one
of the ways that it could be done is by
hiring more anthropologists who do work
that I do within the industry ie the
fashion industry to basically tell these
designers and these businesses ahead of
time act as a consultant say you know
this is the group I work with let me
tell you how things work down there let
me tell you in what ways you can do
actual good and what ways you can do
harm and having more of those within
businesses may help a lot of businesses
are hiring anthropologist now just in
general because there's this kind of new
buzzword within businesses of like
culture but like a business culture
right so they want people who understand
how culture works so part of it I think
would be the responsibility of those
businesses or those designers to take it
upon themselves to care enough to hire
whether it's an anthropologist or
somebody else
can do the same work to hire somebody
who can do work like that but they have
to care first they have to actually
course worry about the fact that they're
appropriate yeah yeah yeah so maybe
there needs to be some sort of like a
like that that first principle system
that you were initially describing to us
on this is how you focus on cultural
exchange yeah okay first one again was
ask
right and then ask in a way where you
recognize your power compared to their
power so like ask power like together
I'm gonna ask power then you know I
guess there's just more ask about where
yeah this is it sacred is it divine your
own research - like there are ways
oftentimes I think with with people
especially if they're already kind of
people lit so within my community within
Ecuador a lot of indigenous people are
so used to anthropologists coming in
that they're just kind of like sure I'll
answer your questions which is sad in to
some extent because it means they're
just used to being this kind of endless
well of knowledge for people who come
right so yeah I mean a lot of it is
asking living with the population making
real relationships but also like there's
information out there there's
information out there on you know sacred
patterns there's information out there
that exists from other anthropologists
or you know from other people doing
similar work about what these textiles
mean within this community so like part
of it is you know also your
responsibility to do not just that
fieldwork part but also start looking
for articles start looking for books
okay so the so these like ask and
research together exactly and understand
power those are kind of the principles
are there other ones that we maybe can
think of so maximizing cultural exchange
yeah I mean those are really those are
the core outside of that it would really
be just kind of fine-tuning then you're
already getting into this piece of the
specific culture right because in some
cultures it might be more appropriate to
in this way versus this way or you might
want to actually live with the family or
you might not want to because that might
be too invasive so really a very gift
that you've researched that they
appreciate that exactly that you were
sir exactly bringing them something and
sometimes within fieldwork there's the
question of what are you giving back and
sometimes people are like well I want to
give them money you know in exchange for
let's say their time or whatever already
not be right and oftentimes it's not
appropriate yeah exactly so see this is
this brings up the point again of the
whole economic machinery thing is that
it's just like if that's if that's not
appropriate in the cultural circumstance
meat they don't want it they don't want
to play in the big Monopoly board game
that the whole planets playing in then
why is it that then that that their
goods even in the first place should
enter into the I guess for awareness
about their story maybe they don't want
that I don't know this is this is all
hard - it all depends and that's the
thing it all depends you have to do
research and ask yeah and the thing is
you know people are going to if they do
just like the people I work with they do
want their dress to be out there not as
necessarily a bought and sold commodity
although they they do say pretty much
for anyone who likes it but they want it
to be out there because for so many
years even using that dress style was
repressed so for a long time it's really
only been the past ten years that
they've started using this dress style
again because prior to that being
visibly indigenous especially if you
were trying to go into the city to get a
job if you were trying to you know kind
of move your way up the ladder you
didn't necessarily want to look visibly
indigenous because you would get treated
terribly you would get things yelled I
mean and this does to some extent still
happen but you get things yelled at you
you'd be made to sit in the back of the
bus you would be called dirty all these
all these different things that are
associated with you looking indigenous
so for them it's actually very very
important that this does circulate and
circulates as widely as possible because
it's about reclaiming the power to
where that dress okay and being visibly
indigenous but you know again like you
said there are some groups that may not
want anything to do with that and they
may feel the actual planet suffering
because of modernity exactly and maybe
piece of it and may not want to enter
into the global economy in the same way
right and so again it's it's all gonna
be very very specific ask research do
hardcore understanding of that and
understand the power dynamic yeah and
then tailor that towards each subculture
so this is yeah this is even going in
having read a lot that is gonna go in
having read a lot
wow what a complex study this is you
just like open up the Canon it's just
pouring out and it also and just like
the big global economic machinery board
game of Monopoly that's happening with
top-down power structures it's just it
doesn't feel as though and I guess okay
if you ask and research and indigeneity
the deceptive culture says yes please I
would like to feel more empowered
wearing my because I wasn't able to
previously wear this and feel empowered
so please help me with that process or
please do share the story of our
subculture through and every single time
somebody gets this the sacred bracelet
with our patterns on it please include a
card about who we are and why this is
sacred in the band on your messaging on
your website on your Instagram on your
Etsy whatever Pinterest etc just include
that okay okay great we can do that then
there's there's there's
just what what is what is it why is it
that it feels like the planet is saying
that modernity is choking ecosystems and
that we have the obsession to continue
propagating subcultures of indigeneity
into that machinery and so that also
feels very it makes me feel unwell at
the same time well and what you're
talking about as modernity is
specifically it's not just the
conceptualization of like a modern
society right it's a very specific
modernity
it's a modernity that we're experiencing
right now that is a Western modernity
that is based on still certain
principles of enlightenment that's based
on Industrial Revolution that's based on
now this mass technology kind of
evolution that's happening it's too
rapid pace it's a very very very
specific form of modernity so with a lot
of indigenous knowledge what's happening
I think or what will probably happen is
that that is gonna start influencing as
opposed to you know everybody thinks of
globalization is like oh yeah Western
civilization just goes out and converts
all these other places into little mini
us's or a little mini Europe's or
whatever it may be when in reality what
happens is you know a mcdonald's goes
into this area and people change it to
make it fit their culture better you
know or it might not succeed because
they don't want it so people really they
absorb what they need but they don't
absorb what they don't need and I think
also there's an increasing movement from
the other end influencing Western
society or what we're calling Western
society I don't think it's just a
one-way road I think it's just that we
tend to ignore the ways that were
influenced by let's say indigenous
economies right my ideas of reciprocity
those are gonna get stronger and
stronger and again that work is being
done by people themselves it's not it's
not up
you know us to say oh yeah let's
integrate this let's let's bring these
people in like they're gonna cause this
shift themselves whoever they are
whether it be you know activists on the
ground or designers or artists or
whoever or people coming up in academia
intellectual intellectuals and that
sphere that these people are gonna be
doing it themselves that it's really not
up to us to say how do we incorporate
you you know I like your focus on the
absolute positive possibility of this
that's where we aim to well yeah right
own in our attention and focus on the
show towards that as well so let's you
know let's say that if you take these
best principles of cultural exchange you
know we go back to the very first thing
we said which is maybe indigeneity plus
modernity can actually be a good
synthesis for a good path forward fine
then you see cultural exchange your
principles you know our ask research
power etc and talked about if you do
that really well you can maybe take some
of the culture of indigeneity and
actually really holistically bring it
and actually take what is like kind of
like a little bit problematic at times
modernity and actually augment it quite
well potentially maybe when there's more
sacred indigenous arts in modernity
maybe people will more frequently be
like well what is that very sacred
necklace that you're wearing right now
what does it actually mean oh it came
from this subculture around the world
that has this story where they feel more
interconnected all the time in these
ways yeah and then all of a sudden
little the same frequency that you see
food restaurants in Metropolis is all of
a sudden you'll see like little like
emotional intelligence centers and
meditation and and yoga
what meaning union with the divine or
with the
one in sanskrit that maybe you'll see
more of those little centers popping up
everywhere so it could be it could be a
way to evolve consciousness that we
don't even know is actually happening
yet like you're indicating and I love
that I love that we're getting there
that's that's so as long as there's no
appropriation that's the thing yeah and
the process does decrease the
appropriation increased that beautiful
cultural exchange okay I'm down that
hard just a little time little effort
that was that was pretty cool I like how
we eat I like how you got there okay
last question okay what's that okay we
asked all our guesses okay what is most
beautiful most beautiful so that's
interesting from somebody who works in
esthetics beauty is subjective in all
ways so I'd say you know on a basic
human level love empathy compassion is
for me the most beautiful thing you know
that sounds a little hokey but it really
is where change comes from I mean yes
change also comes from anger change also
comes from struggle strife but whether
it be kind of an inner sense of love or
a love for your community or a love for
someone you've never met before I love
for your environment or the universe or
whatever it may be that's that's where a
lot of real change comes from I think
help oh sure mm-hmm that means Amen yeah
Wow yep love empathy compassion yeah
that's right
my nieces have been such a pleasure
that's been wonderful thank you so much
thanks for coming on the show
thank you thanks everyone for tuning in
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking about all the
cool stuff that Anais was teaching us
check out her links in the bio below
support her work also check out the
links in the bio blow to American
Anthropological Association check out
their links support them you can find
all of our links in the bio below to
simulation you can support us you can
find our Pay Pal patreon cryptocurrency
leak you design cool merch you get paid
all those links are below and also
support the other artists on screw
spiritual leaders organizations in your
communities and around the world that
you believe in support them and help
them flourish go and build the future
everyone manifest that next world I love
you very much thanks for tuning in we'll
see you soon
Wow yay
[Music]
you
[Music]